absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
I would have led well these episodes
with recent retired players have been
going down an absolute treat with you
guys so I've ramped it up a little bit
more with this time a double Rocky World
Cup winner he's a lad who's played for
plenty of teams including Canterbury the
Crusaders the Highlanders and of course
the All Blacks before heading over to
France we racked up 84 games with Poe he
then finished off in Japan with
Mitsubishi dynabors and he's also
someone who's went through more injury
setbacks than probably any other player
I know and of course he is an absolute
lad as well so I'm stoked to having
water lead it is the great man himself
Colin Slade welcome mate thanks for
having me pleasure to make the cup mate
great to get you in this temporary
Studio that we have here um feels pretty
professional and mate you're looking
good arms are big strong
got the t-shirt on there type cold wash
but um no look yeah again
yeah thanks but thanks for getting me in
here it's uh I've I've certainly seen
this show so it's going well mate you're
you're looking in good neck I mean I see
the recent post that you've retired um
caught me a little bit by surprise I
feel like you're you're still good to go
potentially one more Super season in you
no no to be honest mate like it's all
that all the all the injuries and stuff
like that it was just time to finish up
um you know I'd probably finish you know
I need to sort of announce my retirement
you know this week but not mentally I
would sorry I'd retired maybe six months
ago it was just a case of you know I
want to be 100 sure so you know I took a
little bit of time before I sort of uh
did it and to be honest I'm not that
active on the social media these days so
it was just a case of getting around to
it but uh no I'm done but yeah I'm still
trying to keep fit and trying to keep
some good habits and um yeah
I'm not going to say Never Say Never but
um no I'm yeah I'm done yeah you said
you're 100 sure you're not going to say
anything until you're 100 sure but I
feel a little bit of hesitancy there I
feel like
um it's a couple of Crusader tens go
down early in the season is your is your
phone number available well I'd have to
I'd have to uh contact my new my new
boss so it's uh I've just started
working with Forsyth bars so yeah
um look it's a new exciting adventure
for me something completely different
um sitting at an office um you know a
little bit warmer than training in the
winter time every year for the last sort
of 15 years but
um yeah yeah sort of sort of immerse
myself into something else I've got to
commit to it and uh I'm done how did you
get into that like that seems like a
really quick transition you said that
you've obviously made the decision a
little bit earlier than we've seen it
but
um pretty quick transition into
something completely different so yeah
like I said it might seem like it
because I've only announced it you know
last week but
um you know in my head I'd been finished
for probably three or four months yeah
um I just left that door open purely
because I didn't know if I wanted to
come out to a new job yet and
something might have popped up and I've
sort of been talking whether you know I
wanted to get into coaching at some
point too so
um but you know I parked out and moved
on for now we're going to focus on this
new this new gig and see where it takes
me and and and who knows what uh what
will happen in the future I guess but
I'll do that for now and what does it
involve what what does working for
foresight bar all I know sort of is they
obviously sponsor the stadium down south
but what do they actually do yeah so
full size Forsyth bar is an investment
company that look after people's funds
and manage people's portfolios I guess
and as an investment advisor so that's
what what I'll be when I um you know
when I get the training wheels off from
and at the moment just sort of flick
into our emails and going through
compliance stuff but
um it's early days and yeah like I said
it's uh it's something completely
different but I've always had an
interest in you know the financial
markets and things like that I've always
tried to keep active so
um I thought why not you know give it a
crack and
um see how it goes you know at the end
of the day you know you need a job yeah
and I'll put off for 15 years to get a
real job but you know the times right to
try something else and did you have to
do any study or what did what did that
sort of look like throughout your career
to land in a role like this straight
away yeah so yep you have to study this
various certificates and qualifications
you need for that to be able to provide
Financial advice and
um you know being in Japan over the last
couple of years was a bit of a bit of
spare time there off the field to take
that off so I thought you know I'll I'll
do that just in case you know I wanted
to pursue this career and
um yeah I thought why not you know my
the reason I've got this opportunity I
guess I had a financial advisor
throughout my career to help help me
manage my money and um he kind of went
up the food chain a wee bit and started
you know digging into my elbow uh using
the other words I guess to to ask me if
I was ready to to come on board and
um yeah that's how it worked out right
do you miss rugby I know it hasn't been
too long but have you missed it do you
think you'll miss it um you know if
you'd asked me a year ago I would have
said I don't think I would myself
um and then you do finish and you get
quite nostalgic towards the end and you
realize how how good and the environment
is and I don't miss the injuries and
um you know some of the cold trainings
and stuff like that but you know look it
was a pretty relaxed environment good
bunch of lads pretty much across the
board wherever I played
um
so yeah you do something 15 years mate
you're like you know you know that
the lifestyle I guess and become very
accustomed to it so almost that for sure
but I never say never you know like I
said it might be something I want to get
back into later
um because like you know like I said
Rugby's you know are great to be
involved with so I might
um might try it again later and you did
mention the injuries and you did have
more injuries than most like you
obviously had some extreme highs in your
career but so many lows with
back-to-back injuries and a huge injury
toll I mean how hard was that throughout
your career to deal with all these
injury setbacks yeah I mean it was tough
definitely character building stuff
um
you know a double figure surgeries in
the end and
um it ended up any concussions that
probably got on top of me a wee but over
the last few years I sort of ended up
probably close to double figures as well
quite a few in France so
um and luckily didn't have the symptoms
of some people get so yeah um you know
touch wood see how I go but
I think with injuries yet you sort of
learn how to cope and how to manage and
all that sort of stuff and it certainly
knocked me first uh earlier in my career
where
you know you're getting injury you miss
an opportunity
you can get that opportunity to grow and
develop
um and it can sort of beat you up a
weaver
um
I suppose as you get a little bit older
you use that time to actually get better
in certain areas
um you know obviously no you want to be
playing but you know you sort of yeah
like I said you work away and you sort
of manage it mentally a lot better I
guess and um it is frustrating but
you know there's worse jobs out there
you could be doing and rehabbing back
and still getting paid to rehab and get
get right so it's um yeah that is what
it is yeah was there ever an injury that
you had where you thought about you know
pulling pin on the game that was really
tough for you to sort of get back uh
honestly no not really
um I mean apart from the head knocks
who's been a couple of times over the
last few years where I thought well one
more hit nothing I'm done and then yeah
you know if his law brings up and he
said he gives you another one and you go
one more so that probably happened three
or four times so it's um but in terms of
you know the broken bones and things
like that not really
um I was too young yeah to really put
that to bed and I wouldn't have had the
closure yeah if I'd given away given it
up and walked away and it wasn't in my
character either to be honest mate like
it sort of rolled the sleeves up sort it
out come back
um gives you a bit of motivation to do
that and those those injuries with the
timeline like the brakes and stuff there
I guess you get the whole you got your
time frame to process it and you know
when you're coming out with a head knock
is a bit different eh like you don't
actually know when you're going to come
right and it's a bit more a bit more
hard mentally to deal with yeah and and
fear of the unknown right like what
you're going to be like in the future
and yeah like I said for some reason I
just keep getting these head knocks and
I would wake up okay and yeah
um you know some of them I got up on
Hospital once don't remember a thing and
then woke up fine the next day and it's
not to say like
I'm toughening up or anything like that
which I think I've got mates who have
had one and had to retire like it's
quite a puzzling sort of injury yeah and
I got lucky in terms of the the side
effects after but you know I mean we'll
we're all unsure about the long-term
effects for now I'll be out of the way
and
um
no problem at the moment yeah do you
have any concerns like how do you feel
like mentally you feel like your memory
and stuff's good or obviously test out
pretty soon as we go through your career
but how do you feel about like your your
mental space I think as you get older
too you start you mean we get to the
Cloudy anyway doesn't it whether that's
you know the age or or the kids that
give you the broken sleep or
I always see it as I was learning new
languages I was forgetting English you
know it was uh
but um yeah I mean there's always
concerns but I mean a lot of a lot of
the concerns that are in the in the
public are generated from the media and
we've got to remember the media's
entertainment Focus click focus and all
that sort of stuff and and it's not to
discreet anything but you know I listen
to
um neurologists and things like that and
I went on my own way Tour de France at
the time and went around about three or
four neurologists just to
um you know to check to cross-check to
make sure everyone was delivering the
same message and they were all pretty
consistent yeah without queuing them on
anything in terms of that I mean a lot
of them were sort of saying a lot of the
stuff out of America is a little bit
hyped and a little bit um
you know yeah
there are definitely kill officials NFL
players I mean I taught to take away the
heads I've gone
um
obviously
don't quote me but you know there's a
fear about a drug usage and things like
that and there's obviously a pretty gun
happy culture there are different sort
of
um I guess culture than in us that
um but
yeah and saying yeah I listen to the new
neurologist there's no real evidence and
there's always going to be a section of
society that do have
um problems cognitively um
and it magnifiers should be no different
we're going to have a section of regular
players who
who are going to have issues and whether
it's whether it's related to he knocks
or not or just being part of society who
have that genetic component does that
make sense yeah mate you're giving me
hope you give me hope that my friends
sorry I'm trying to get myself good
confidence you know like it's uh yeah I
think it is a worrying thing right
especially when you get kids and things
like that you don't want to be
um for all intensive purpose is a bit
more vegetable or not be able to
remember things or I mean that is a
concern
um but but you're not there yet you're
ready to go you've got your memory
that's right yeah I'm going to use my
brain in the real world now so I need it
for a little bit longer well let's use
it now and go back to sort of the start
of your journey obviously you're a true
Canterbury and born and bred at
Christchurch
um what was your upbringing like here
yeah I mean yep um like any kiwi cat I
guess you grew up wanting to be an all
black or a black cat for me like a lot
of my you know earlier time was more
Cricket phones but yeah yeah I love my
Cricket
um
but uh yeah played for mirabile Lincoln
or Merlin's at various times remember
Pat back in my day just showing me uh my
age but
um yeah grew up went to
brains or healed primary brains in
Christchurch sports high school and and
that's where I guess like like anyone
you know the sport influence and the
competitive aspect of it starts to ramp
up a wee but when did rugby takeover
from cricket
um so I was
seventh form I think it was where I
started playing both and then got the
opportunity to play to trial for New
Zealand 19s
and yeah there was a Canterbury 119
Cricket tournament on at the same time
but I sort of figured that well once
finished yelling so I'll give that one a
crack and
um yeah when Wright made the team and
that was sort of I wouldn't say it was
forced on me but it sort of made my
decision for me I guess and then from
that the academy and that sort of
rolled on from that but it is way later
than I expected I thought it might have
been you know sort of third form because
back end of your Christchurch boys high
time you were you're an absolute gun
there was huge wraps on you as a play
obviously played against you in the
final at Jade Stadium you guys had a
stack team some batemans and Owen Franks
Ash Dixon's horror the list goes on met
Todd mate the Simone it was well we had
an awesome team moment
um yeah I'm not trying to do my own
trumpet but the the team performed
really well when um we had a great set
of guys I thought we didn't lose a game
for two years
um so that I sort of think that you know
being in a good environment early sort
of you know gives you that enjoyment
Factor but you also you also class above
like a lot of the players in the
competition at the time you were kicking
off both feet like easily and um he had
all the skills you know so
um made you made it look like you were a
full full-on rugby professional playing
against amateurs at the time I
appreciate that thank you very much but
yeah I mean you know yourself as a team
that you're in a good team I think it's
a bit easier so you know you benefit
from that you get the confidence and
like I mentioned the enjoyment factor of
being in a dominating team
um and then that becomes sort of a new
standard behavior and that's sort of the
way it went right through we went to Old
Boys same thing sort of happened we had
it an outrageously good team there with
you with your mate Mike Coleman there
he was a man you lived with him didn't
you yeah yeah had the pleasure all the
misfortunes
the guy doesn't like the shower does he
not no he used to come home from
training go straight to bed daddy oh
mate he kept that quiet yeah hey but no
he was he was a pleasure um and liberal
sewing pranks at the same time yeah he'd
have a couple of guys that sort of
popped in school mates that popped in
and out but
um yeah that was an interesting period
and then from there you said like you
obviously went through the New Zealand
age grades
um New Zealand 19s New Zealand 21s what
was that like yep I mean that was really
good um you know again it was sort of
like
what what seemed as a far away goal
started to get a little bit closer right
you made these teams in it sort of it
makes you feel like you're not far off
so again it sort of incentivizes you to
to give it a bit more and
um yeah that was great playing with
um I guess guys that even some guys I
watched on TV didn't I tend to make the
NPC well I can't remember what it was
called then but yeah
um for the smaller unions and you sort
of like oh heck you know I'm starting to
play with some serious uh some serious
weapons here but um
yeah uh it was yeah part of part of the
journey I guess and and getting a bit
more exposure to some some good coaches
and stuff really helped were you
confident in your own ability did you
believe that you're gonna go on and
become an all black did you have this
self-belief
um I think I I suffered a little bit
early on I was quite a shy sort of guy
so you know especially when I got into
those environments I was quite internal
um and probably didn't didn't believe
but
um and I actually messaged uh Rob Penny
last night who message me after I sort
of just announced my retirement I said
like you're one of the guys who who
brought that out of me it was so
positive and and but John Haggett as
well that I had in my first couple of
years with Canterbury just really got it
sort of giving me enough of a rope to be
able to drive a team and obviously
younger you're not going to get the full
license you know but
um you know they gave me the confidence
I guess to sort of grow as a person
um I think the ability was were there or
the the route uh what do you call it the
Sprouts of the bloody yeah whatever they
were there the ability was there but
um it's not until you get that sort of
confidence and that personality and the
mental stuff sorted that they start to
actually grow as a team I mean and that
you're going into a pretty stacked
Canterbury side at the time what was it
like that was obviously pretty like like
you say pretty intimidating to be
bossing around it would have been all
blacks and plenty of Super Rugby players
at the time for a young 10 to just jump
in there what was that like yeah I mean
first day of training I think I turned
up and it was you know Karen Reed he
wasn't the all black Captain then he was
still playing item cup but you know I
sort of years before I sort of watched
all those guys Andy Alice was passing me
the ball and I knew Andy from from
younger actually he was another uh he
would probably yeah
surely more yeah he looks a lot older
though doesn't it but um
but um yeah and all of a sudden you're
sort of training with them and again
that makes it easier right as a young
team coming in and
I've got the ability to sort of sit back
and story about myself and they they
take control of that leadership stuff
certainly helped and then you went
pretty quickly you went through the
Crusaders the following year I'm
obviously playing behind DC and Stephen
Brett I think too was it well DC wasn't
there that was that yeah he went to
France so that's true yeah I sort of got
first crack at it there and we sort of
struggled to wee bit and then I ended up
getting shifted to the wing
um which again was part of my journey
right like in those sort of things that
I wouldn't say it was challenging but
well sorry it wasn't challenging from a
bit like in terms of handling being
moved to the wing but it was certainly
beneficial
um in the long term yeah it was that was
a tough pill to swallow at the time not
playing 10 but in geez I was 20 21 or
whatever
um and just sort of rolled it up and
rolled up my sleeves and sort of gave it
a crack on the wing and ended up playing
about 9-10 games straight yeah had you
played Wing before was this um I think
maybe maybe a game or two for it when I
was on the first 15 yeah just because I
was at skinny white guy they needed to
kick her so it was a slight Chuck them
on there and he can kick the goals but
just don't do anything else so yeah but
apart from that no certainly not um
played a bit of fullback yeah these days
it's not too similar I guess and what
were you go kicking when you're on the
wing like
Shucks I can't remember yeah he's the
concussion yeah
that was nearly 15 years
yeah but I can't remember maybe Britain
yeah
Stevie bootmaster and how was it like in
that environment like we've sort of
spoken about the Canterbury about the
step up to the Crusaders I probably
found that a little bit harder because
you know Richie the All Blacks are back
right so Richie and the Brad thorns and
yeah they're a lot more authoritative
and um
um and it was probably I sort of noticed
I guess the tail end of that sort of
older culture where it sort of
transitioned the way but throughout my
career and the coaches sort of drove
this whole
as time went on I guess making young
guys feel comfortable in the environment
and it wasn't there maybe uncomfortable
it was just you know like I said I was
quite a shy internal sort of guy and
they're in their respect right yeah yeah
you have to
um and it probably took me a while to be
fear but um but yeah I was still pretty
Starstruck by those guys for quite a
while
um I remember one time we went out to
dinner with them and you know you sort
of break off into your
but I missed I missed the Young Guy's
bus I got stuck and I looked around and
it was just like
Richie if dawny
um crocky you know
I remember sitting here and I didn't say
a thing I just remember being so shy can
I say something when I pipe up and yeah
and that was that sort of summed it up
yeah it was just I wasn't that
comfortable at that stage but I was
comfortable in the field
um in terms of playing getting
comfortable but yeah just handling those
guys was a little bit uh took a year or
two yeah
yeah in the trust I guess yeah so
calling the shots and stuff this stuff
there's no issue there no one was trying
to override you or didn't feel like they
didn't trust you on the field it was
just off the field it was awkward yeah I
mean yeah I mean they
whether that whatever
their their status like if they still
need direction from their team so that's
your job and that was still my my
expectation of myself so and that's what
the coaches put on me but yeah like I
said it was more handling the the
leadership side and uh yeah off the
field of social stuff as well just being
like yeah hi Richie do you feel that
never really changed you know like it
was sort of that way through hey what's
up man
fuel don't hate me
yeah yeah I mean actually as you get on
and get a little bit older and go
through the things with them they start
to loosen up but yeah
um yeah still yeah I guess the
allegiance of the game that's still uh
yeah it's what happens these days
I did actually not too long ago the uh
kids trampoline park
hi Richie
did he not remember yeah
physio
oh it's good stuff and then obviously
the All Blacks like I think it was the
following year right like it all
happened quick for you you went bang
bang bang and did you feel like you were
ready for the All Blacks or how did you
even been how did you get named as an
all black um
um to answer that question the answer
would be no I didn't feel I didn't feel
really only because of the way it sort
of happened I sort of got rung up by
Darren Chand at the time
um and I came in first as an injury
placement so he sort of said oh mate we
need someone to come along it was a day
camp in Christchurch so yeah and we just
had some extra bodies so uh can you come
down I sort of went down there and
um just at the day actually we you know
such wasn't going to be ready by next
week could you come up you know and I
thought all right you know I I didn't
think too you never actually got named
but then the next day oh yeah I've been
called up to the All Blacks and I was
like
how do I how do I confirm this like is
that what am I in the squad like
um yeah and then you go up there and I
didn't I didn't have a real expectation
of playing and I probably got through
the first week as you do um and in the
second week I sort of looked around and
it was like no spear backs oh yeah
um and yeah it turns out like I was that
close to playing I think I think it was
Corey Jane or something like that was
injured and they were obviously going to
put someone to start to replace them and
he ended up playing but yeah I was until
the Friday I was like seeing him what
you might be in the team so just be
ready I thought I was just yeah yeah but
um yeah
um and I didn't play that first year so
um you know I missed out in India tour
came back the next year I got called
under the replacement again it was this
was 2010 or whatever and then I did play
and made my debut that year later so um
yeah and what was it like what was it
like making your debut
um that's pretty surreal
um particularly coming off of the bench
and like I got called in as a ninja
replacement again so I sort of flew in
there got named straight on the bench
this time they told me you know you're
entertainment stuff so I sort of could
be here
um and yeah I suppose sitting there
watching you sort of felt more of a
spectator yeah yeah and you'll send your
numbers up in the phone
yeah and it's yeah it's a pretty crazy
feeling like you sort of
ample energy and just so much enthusiasm
and excitement the adrenaline's probably
the best way to describe it it's just
incredible um but it goes pretty quick
and
um thankfully we won that game
um pretty good vibe after the game and
uh yeah makes a difference and obviously
the hacker as well like going from the
hacker to the bench what's that like
obviously you're a big hacker ma'am you
always had a good pecan Etc so what was
that what's the news like pre-hacker
um well I think because I'm you know
clearly not an intimidating physically
intimidating bloke
um yeah I sort of gave it everything in
the gray and through a couple of times
just sort of be a bit bloody uh blackout
at the end but uh it's pretty much your
concussions have come from well
thankfully I go back to the bench after
and regroup yeah yeah so yeah I don't
know what it would have happened if I
had to start but um yeah again I mean
you're still for the most part you're
still a fan going into the environment
right like it's such a or around it and
you sort of but like holy I can't
believe I'm here for a for a while
actually you know it's not like it's
just done after the first game I think
it's um
yeah it's still still pretty surreal I
guess to to call yourself like and all
that sort of stuff young and
Oh my Jesus it feels a lifetime ago now
yeah it's being on the outside now you
sort of uh you know what it's like being
on the inside and eat it but it just
seems so yeah yeah it seems like an
absolute eternity there you go now and I
guess when you're like sort of on the
fringes all the time like I guess you
ended up playing a fair few tests but
you never really cemented yourself as
that sort of First Choice 10 so you're
always sort of feeling like you're not
quite I don't know involved or running
you've got the license to run the ship
100 especially as a 10 you kind of need
that so
um you know I found myself quite often
sort of being that third ten um so I
wouldn't even get stripped I was
understand more games in the stand true
on the bench even or on the field so
um but I mean it was still awesome yeah
it'd be fundraise especially come World
Cup time and stuff like that to be able
to sort of be on the inside of of a
pretty tight Circle in those times
um you know and and be able to
contribute and help those other guys
um and I sort of you know I took took my
own sort of way but like hey come in the
best environment in the world to be the
best athlete I can be so just train
um and don't look at it as a mess week
just training PBS and all that sort of
stuff yeah and if your number gets
called you know it gets cold but
um yeah the times when I did but
obviously I missed out a bit but yeah
and that's the reason why at the end the
end of the day I ended up going overseas
you know nothing nothing is that ever is
given to you and expect you never expect
in the All Blacks but by the same token
I'd sort of been in and out like you
said for quite a while so it was time to
go overseas and and that worked out well
too and talk to us about the lead up to
obviously 2011 Rugby World Cup huge
moment here in New Zealand
um
did you were you confident you were
going to make that Squad initially yeah
it was a weird it was a weird year
um so I broke my jaw that year that's
right um Islanders you just moved the
preseason preseason so I didn't play any
games and then all of a sudden came back
um after six or seven weeks and then
hit three games and managed to play
really well
um but broke my drawer again
I wasn't really thinking World Cup but
then you know all of a sudden it started
getting phone calls from people like
videos and oh yeah I'm just keeping an
eye on you and you know having to do a
few mental skill stuff since I mean sort
of your age just sort of start to
connect the dots away but you know the
three games you did play he played well
and we like the cut of your jib so yeah
that was
um
yeah I started going to do some
leadership stuff during the time and it
was just like year end yeah so
um and up dancing question was I
confident going I don't know because I
didn't play any rugby that year I played
three games and
and then you go straight into we had a
test in Fiji that was my first game I
think I played a club game or something
before that but
um and then we played straight into
short and try Nations into World Cup so
um and none of those games are played
more 40 minutes so that's what I was
going to look up and
actually because I sort of rushed back
so quickly I ended up pulling my groin
about two weeks before
um they're trying Nations oh yeah and I
couldn't kick oh that's true I ended up
having this like adult
um ended up getting like quite bad
osteotis pubis
basically like some too much tension on
your groin one cider pulled down the
other and you sort of get a bit of a
pelvic bone sort of uh imbalance
um but yeah days off couldn't go
couldn't walk couldn't get out of bed
that sort of stuff all the way through
the World Cup
um
so that was really hard to be able to
handle that as a young guy on the big
stage and then all of a sudden DC was
the one that goes down with the crook
groin I'm going hang on I'm the one with
the crooks
um you know pretty much getting physio
twice a day yeah and on
anti-inflammatories for about nine weeks
straight just to survive yeah and then
all of a sudden my number you know my
number was cold yeah
good Lord like what out of all the time
yeah your bits to be yeah functioning
and training as best as you can you
can't say um yeah I was undercooked but
um geez what an experience so yeah um
you obviously don't end well for me
getting injured yeah the game after but
uh but you sort of knew did you feel
like that was about was going to happen
obviously with you yeah yeah there was
no surprise to you no no it was a matter
of when not after yeah um and because I
wasn't playing at DC most games we only
had two tens back then DC would play a
60 and I walk 70 or whatever it was and
if we had the game wrapped up I'd come
on for 15. yeah whatever it is yeah
um so I wasn't having high high volume
so I was getting by but as soon as I
sort of had to go more than I paid 60
against Canada or seven against Canada I
couldn't kick all week like oh yeah
yes that is what it is but yeah it was
awesome to get that monkey off our back
as a team I guess and ride that wave of
the country it was uh it was pretty
special and how much pressure did you
feel come instantly on you when DC went
down like
yeah yeah it was um I certainly a lot
um and it was that was a more
frustrating thing as it was under the
handy to be able to be able to shoulder
that burden um and the team was a little
bit a little bit different back then
um
wasn't as structured as it was when from
to say after the World Cup when
um Grant whom he left and and Steve
Hansen took over with yeah it became
quite a structured sort of game plan
yeah from then on and it could sort of
as you can see and happened over the
years you could sort of plug out a
couple of players plug in a new one that
was sort of quite yeah you know the ship
would run
um but those sort of days everything was
tailored to
the players who was expected to be
starting so yes I could kept their foot
but I had to wish down on the left-hand
side because that's where DC was for
example so and that didn't change so you
know I was
um
still playing what was asked of DC you
know yeah because he was expected to be
there all the rest of it so and all of a
sudden yeah like I said it sort of fell
on him while he was there and he'd gone
it was kind of a little bit like
everyone was like
looking at each other sort of thing yeah
um I mean the beaver saying the same
thing in his one like he he was asked to
do all these kicks that DC used to do
but they weren't part of his game they
weren't his strength so he always felt
like he was trying to be DC when
um he clearly wasn't yeah I mean it's
pretty hard pretty big boots to follow
especially back then you know dizzy was
in his prime and yeah
um but yeah uh it didn't work out anyway
and I ended up shouldn't have been
getting anything
the dear full confidence in Beaver did
you did you know he was going to be able
to well I didn't really hear the ship
home because when he came in I had to
leave so I didn't see or anything of him
while he was in there what do you mean
you have to let well as soon as he got
injured you were gone yeah next day flew
home oh really pretty brutal I come back
for the game the following week yeah but
I mean it was only because like 100 in
the quarterfinal so I missed the the
semi-final prep in the final prep sure
come back for the game so was that just
the tournament rules or yes yeah but so
the DC hit the leave as well he was
living in Auckland so he said okay he's
did the same game as me but he was in
Auckland so he said oh yeah yeah hung
around but so he flew down to
Christchurch he didn't even see the back
end of the world cup other than the game
no oh I mean I had to have I had surgery
went home and
I got an infection end up in hospital
yeah long story but yeah down that road
but uh one of those other surgeries that
I had to do but yeah so you had to have
surgery on your groin post that yeah
injury I got an infection in the surgery
and
even the week of the final amount I
wouldn't be hospital bed all week
had to get a exemption from the match
day doctor uh final to fly me up he was
going to look after me had to get the
injections half time
far out I had to Dripping my arm by
myself on the stage and [ __ ]
but yeah so no post-match celebrations
for you well they let me but to be
honest yeah
yeah you went and hit up the gym in the
morning with the Frank's voice
I think they learned from that one when
we won 15 I don't know I don't think
they did I think they afforded
themselves a day off
yeah Special yeah so then let's let's go
straight to the um 2015 one like the
build up obviously a bit different but
how was that for you
um that one was that one was an
enjoyable World Cup right we went in the
spotlight of we were here and we could
go out we could do stuff you know in New
Zealand you're sort of stuck to your
hotel and literally that was all we did
except CJ and
um
it turns out but
um yeah 15 was a great time aren't you
going into World Cup that was my last
stunters and All Blacks I knew I was
going to enjoy it I see you'd already
signed with Poe at the stage yep I sort
of been upset did you know that was that
ever going to affect your chances of
making the world capital Did they'd ever
come into your process
um it certainly does right like you want
to you want to play the World Cup but
um
yeah you have to actually pick me up
yeah you didn't you didn't have
discussions with them whether yeah yeah
I mean they're trying pretty hard for me
to stay back at the Crusaders by that
stage
um and we were going right um we didn't
go right that yeah but you know I was
playing the right so um and DC was
leaving so you know Steve obviously
wants to keep as many players as he
wanted to but you know I had to set my
mind on playing overseas early rather
than later I think
um you know you sort of get caught in
the spiral of uh messages I guess that
to stay in New Zealand lead loyal and
that's fine some guys want to do it but
it's a big world out there and we didn't
have kids I was 27 28. going overseas
and experiencing that and geez I'm glad
I did no so cool like the experiences
you get over there like like you say and
even in front I never played in France
one of the places I didn't play but
watching it just what they're getting
like how they support their teams and
getting behind their competitions pretty
impressive eh some of my best memories
of opening memories are in France yeah
um and that's not to discredit New
Zealand but most crowds over there are
just so passionate so even when you play
away it's a great environment yeah it's
just uh pretty daunting but yeah so
passionate after games everything like
that just yeah yeah it's an amazing
amazing place but even outside of rugby
just being able to travel do all that
sort of stuff
um you know I think we all sort of get
caught up in our rugby careers during
that time and it's fine but you know
this is part of just a small part of our
lives
and being able to go overseas and do all
that sort of stuff no memories at all
you know I'll never never forget and
back to that 2015 World Cup so were you
expecting to make that squad or you saw
it on The Fringe again well
I'd play 2014 played at the All Blacks
yeah
um and gone right in India to it so I
had a good idea I got a feeling anyway
but yeah I suppose it was confirmed when
cruden um Aaron broke because oh that's
right yeah um ACL maybe earlier in the
season so yeah I
yeah
that sort of helped my chances or some
cemented my chances I guess but I mean
even then I think you know I kind of
knew you had dizzy Bodie I was going to
be number three and like mentally I
accepted that I was going to be ready
but
um
but I wasn't going to let that affect me
and obviously not having enjoyed 2011 I
knew I was going to go in there and you
know in terms of the
um the whole frustration of the whole
thing and everything
um but going into 15 I knew I was going
to enjoy what's my last crack and I just
love it and and I don't even know I
wasn't playing I said no it was a yeah
that was a great great way to finish my
all day career yeah and was it the lead
up to that tournament where you I
remember you kicking a real clutch goal
against the wallabies I can't remember
exactly where it fits on the time frame
but yes that was 2014 that was a year
before but yeah yeah what do you
remember about that moment obviously
teams on the teams on you kicking the
goal whether we win or not lose the game
and you know what New Zealand's like
with all that games a lot of pressure on
your shoulders to kick a winning goal
like that I might have been going to
Frontier really
probably wouldn't come back either
yeah
um yeah I mean it's obviously yeah a
highlight of my career yeah
um plenty of team highlights but an
individual one that one was too so
um I think you know the amount of times
I've done that in the backyard as a as a
nine-year-old
um I was definitely ready for it you
know um it's stuff dreams are made up I
guess and get the opportunity and then
be able to be able to do it pretty uh
pretty awesome a confident lining up
Kicks like that and we always like
throughout your career you always had a
fair few clutch kicks we're always
confident lining that back yourself in
these situations I mean not always and I
think that's something you develop and
that would be you know advice that I
sort of pass on now is
um you know we tend to think of the
negative if we miss but it is like a
hell of a good challenge to get
something get an opportunity like that
and
um I've sort of shaped it quite a lot
over the years and changed my my
mentality around that sort of stuff that
it is um you know
if you just do normal things you're only
going to get normal results you're going
to get those you know those
extraordinary opportunities is when you
get the you know the rewards and things
like that and the satisfaction and
so yeah even now like you know if we're
playing a game I did lawn bowls the
other day with my first work function
and you know you want to go last you
want that pressure ball yeah they're the
sort of things you come up clutch
no I went the wrong way that's not
something I'll back my skill with you
know like cooking I've done ten thousand
I feel like I've done my ten thousand
hours you know yeah yeah yeah well
[Laughter]
and it you spoke about the lack of game
time at that World Cup I think one game
against the nabia where you got the
crack but
um yeah I did I actually did my Hemi in
that game too so it's sort of yeah you
went seen home though I told the physio
no it's not too bad but I knew 13 I
probably was going to have a couple of
weeks to get right if needed
um and I didn't want to be the guy that
get kicked out of two World Cup so
um yeah it wasn't a bad one I could
still jog I just couldn't Sprint but
yeah it wasn't needed so
about them and what were you like
watching the final
um it was I was pretty pumped yeah so I
remember I remember it very well because
you know we had our bonus I know that's
something at the moment but but you know
obviously is that we put so much effort
into this and we had so many guys
retiring and yeah obviously myself you
know yeah to elicit agree leaving that
that environment
um did anyone carry you on their
shoulders I remember you yeah yeah
it was just one other bloke but no no no
I don't mean I had the moment they
deserved it but um yeah it was it was
messed up I was sitting I had Willie if
you go there next to me and I am white
Crockett and Al Rogers were it was their
um I.T guy
um no Joe Locke a media guy anyway
um and we were just we were over hyping
it we were probably the most
and the stands but uh it was awesome it
was just an unbelievable experience ever
yeah if you were on the field would you
have um scored that try what do you
reckon have you ever thought about that
obviously Bend if it's a kick through
you're fresh
what a journey that would have been what
a way to finish and kicked it off yeah
bad foot that's easy for you though
right but yeah it was it was equally as
good you know like it's um like I said
we had so many Legends going out it was
a good way to finish and you moved to
France so you did go a bit earlier what
what was your reason you did want to
play on these bigger games over there
but obviously financially rumors have
circled around the size of that tape
package and my word that was it would
have been pretty hard to turn down is
that the big reason or the exchange that
went quite good afterwards
um
is the financial advisor you're always
making those thoughts um
yeah initially obviously you you're
going to secure some bank that's right
but um like I mentioned it was a good
life experience to go overseas and live
somewhere else it was something I always
wanted to do um so yeah money stacks up
but do you want to give up on your dream
you have to weigh that up
um I was in a bit of a battle so
you know I've done it for sort of five
or six years but so I felt like I'd take
that box play the two World Cups money
yep let's show that up but also let's go
and travel and do some stuff and then
kids and I was actually a chat with um I
called both
um Harley Williams and Corey Flynn who
who were both over and were overseas at
the time and they both loved it the
comment that stuck with me was if I knew
it was this good I would have come
earlier and I figured at 27 I could have
gone it was dog [ __ ] I'd come back yeah
you know I could could do plenty of you
guys do but
um but yeah nothing would be worse than
going up at 32 thinking this is awesome
um I should have come earlier and I'm
glad I did because you know we went over
there no kids for a couple of years and
just traveled it's pretty much not a
country we went to we didn't go to
um
and yeah then kids came along and we
couldn't do anything like that we're out
here let's go to Japan yeah where was
your favorite spot to travel ah all
different for different things he also
got you know the Greek Islands and that
sort of stuff Croatia they were amazing
for that sort of Lifestyle but then
you've got the history like I'm out of
you know the random stuff I've done I've
got a history degree
um and I've studied all the you know all
that sort of stuff and even see him even
in London and stuff like that that sort
of stuff's pretty cool but then you know
you go or anywhere Barcelona and it's
just amazing there's so much history
over there Italy obviously um Rome was
probably was the first place I went to
and it was just you know mind-blowing
stuff over there to be able to go over
and see it in the flesh yeah so cool and
um you obviously had heaps of kiwis at
power as well Conrad Smith Ben Smith
came wapa all these guys have been on so
um what was it like playing with them oh
that was awesome
um yeah yeah I mean it's it's
interesting to play against them with
these guys in a new general environment
yeah overseas and it's you become way
tighter because of the you know the
smaller group he is right so it's um the
family's got pretty tight you know we
had a great time over there geez we um
you know we we went up and down with the
rugby we had some good times but you
know the off the field stuff the
memories that we did we created uh were
pretty special
again it definitely helps we had a
massive kiwi contingent and since one
one of them left we had another one come
in yeah
um kiwi coaching staff it was uh yeah
great part of the world mate great part
of the world and how did you find the
style of footy over there compared to
here yep so it's um
yeah it was challenging right you're not
playing with
All Blacks you're playing with French
guys who are good on their own right and
certainly the best former international
team at the moment but it was more the
mentality of the play and you've got to
adjust your game style to that they're
not they don't win because of skill they
win because of passion and heart and all
that sort of stuff that just incredible
incredible rugby players when they when
they apply themselves so you sort of
have to manage a game plan to how
they're feeling all right let's flare on
let them go
um if they're not then you're gonna have
to kick it yeah and manage it that way
but and obviously you know we're all
about detail here in New Zealand yeah
they're not about detailed again about
passion so filling in the blanks with a
bit of passion which is something that
I've learned now as a coach is that
um you can get caught up on detail a lot
sometimes too much detail createsability
hesitancy right and you're sort of like
seek and guess yourself whereas you know
roll the sleeves out get into it if you
want to tackle that guy you'll tackle
him as opposed to potentially you know
getting your foot in the right spot
ready ready right all that sort of stuff
um so that's stuff that I've learned now
and can appreciate that from a from an
hour coaching perspective but
um yeah again plenty of plenty of
learnings on how to you know how to
operate and you had to adapt to the
French line yeah it's interesting
hearing you're managing the emotions of
the team so like picking out when
they're good to go when they're not just
through emotions they're so different to
what it's like here yeah yeah and I mean
even when you're at home or away you do
play differently yeah um because that
pulls on the emotions yeah sure yeah is
that why they lose so like I mean always
win their home games and lose their away
games is that basically technically I
mean they've gotten better yeah we've
got we've got a bit better and we had
some kiwi guys sort of involved so that
mentality we tried to sort of get rid of
but yeah for the most part yeah the fans
do play a big big part of whether it's
swinging the players or the rest they
have this thing where the home crowd
just continually whistles at the big
screen and obviously the big screen is
kind of controlled by like a HomeTown TV
man so it's uh unique Foul Play comes up
it's just on repeat repeat the worst
thing starts the Riff has to make a call
you get one in the bed sure yeah that's
pretty much how it happened so
yeah but it's still part of the theater
yeah or French rugby right like that's
what it's that's what it is so cool so
then why did you go to Japan what what's
the reason behind the move to Japan
um just age yes yeah too many games
games long Seasons uh no long Seasons up
there and it's not necessarily just the
games you play it's
repetitude
repetitiveness
repetitiveness of of the training the
the environment
um you know you're basically together as
a squad for 46 weeks 45 weeks whatever
it is you're five weeks after it all
over again so it's not like in New
Zealand you do your item Club you go to
your Super Rugby or you
um yeah all blacks whatever you're
mixing up the environment but yep just
needed a change too many head knocks
um play some easier rugby and and had
the family a little bit closer to home
so we started to accumulate kids while
we're overseas you see so all of a
sudden being a little bit home for
longer and impressive grandparents
became a bit more of a priority how many
kids have you got so I've got three
three girls three three girls oh there
you go the girl dead
um so yeah five three and one um so
they're in good hands that you all go
yeah yeah so that's why I had to get
back to the workforce match I had to get
to the office get out look I'm out
I can't help sorry
[Laughter]
so what why do you choose uh the dino
boss the Doug picking pool was it yeah
no it was just quite honestly they had a
spot yeah they needed a 10 and they had
a kiwi coach there who I'd had a
previous relationship with
um
um it was managed in London 21 coach so
agree Cooper so he yeah he had that
connection and got me over there but
you don't really turn down a gig over
there anyway that's quite a good coping
you sort of just take it
um depending on the time you've got the
rules around care players you can only
have certain amount of international
players and a squad so they've got a
spot for it for an international tenure
you kind of jump it up it was a perfect
thing for me it worked out really well
I'm a great part of the world to live in
we dealt with covert but
so we didn't get the full package but
true was that covered both years you
were there pretty much yeah I mean
they're still dealing with it now to a
certain extent a little bit better but
not not so much the outbreak it's just
more or government restrictions it's
just team restrictions don't get covered
pretty much and they listen over there
it's weird culture where they actually
listen to your government listen to
everything and no one will walk across
the road without a green green walking
man ever everything like that it's uh
yeah funny now you sort of see like
kiwis that sort of rebellious I guess
you'll certainly express our
disappointment and things but you know
let us yeah shut up and comply and it's
uh it's interesting yeah did you feel
that on the field as well with the
players and like the rugby culture as
well very um yes coach I'll do that
coach yeah exactly
um yeah that's I mean and they look for
they look to be told they don't assume
um so you had to deal with that too but
again it was my job there as a as an
experienced team going over there and
helping out
um you know a young team or we were a
dip 2 Team coming up to div one
and again just another awesome
opportunity to get a life experience and
go and play in a different culture and
live there and you summed up the French
and you know Style with emotions and
juggling their emotions how would you
sum up the Japanese
style what do you have to weigh up there
well it's probably the inverse you know
like they would tend to go in their
shallowy but if they made mistakes and
wouldn't get it like a motion they'd get
shy and
um yeah I mean
yeah uh just a different different set
you know like I said they sort of Look
to You to tell them what to do and it
doesn't go wrong it's um
actually blame you at all but it's just
it is what it is and
yeah I found that different challenge
but yeah it was quite nice sort of just
being their teacher and helping them as
much as I can no doubt they're in a
better place with um their experience
with you well you have to ask him that
but uh yeah we'll see how they go this
year I guess but I didn't play a lot
last year I sort of uh yeah had a few
injuries last year so that's why yeah
sort of culminated in me uh retiring any
major injuries those ones was that hit
again yeah yes I sort of got chucked on
my head a bit of a spear tackle and felt
a bit of a crack on my neck so I tried
to sort of attire a little bit earlier
but
yeah got tempted to come back and play
and then yeah and snapped my bicep ten
minutes back into my comeback game and
that was the end of my career so so you
got more surgery for the road yeah you
got an extra what two year and a half
paid if you're like if you had of ended
your career that first time you oh that
was on my last year so yeah yeah so you
just saw out the rest of your contract
yeah um sort of had about three months
to sort of uh navigate I guess and then
came back and got injured again and
fun way to retire and no more injuries
since touchwood but you'll be playing
touch tonight too won't you so have you
how are you going on the touch field I'm
not playing tonight oh you're not all
right yeah I did the queen marathon on
the weekend you see my toenails are
black so I can't put my boots on so what
inspired you to do a marathon uh yeah
good question I'm questioning that now
myself yeah no I thought well you know
it's one of one of those bucket listings
too you want to do at some stage and I
thought well
I'm only just retired I'm only still
semi-athletic enough to be able to cope
what I thought I'd be able to cope I
mean she fell to pieces at the end and
um but yeah it's a big commitment don't
it yeah training and all that sort of
stuff but I thought why not do it and
how much training did you put in before
us
um yeah quite a bit yep yep so I did I
did quite a bit I thought I got myself
the best shot but yeah I got caught up
on the Hills a wee bit and yeah
what do you mean caught up on the Hills
what what does that mean uh well no I
just sort of ran out of path yeah if you
don't train Hills you know it was quite
early yeah yeah it wasn't I'd been
running around Hickory Park which you
would have found now makes a pretty flat
uh running joke but
um yeah it had on those Hills and it
sort of beat me up a wee but she didn't
have enough gas in the tank but
hmm so what what happened they did just
just hit the wall mate you know people
will tell you about this Marathon wall
and just uh you hit the wall and just
run out of fuel your legs to cramp up
and you just oh yeah sort of a walk jog
for the last sort of 3K oh it's a bit
frustrating because I yeah had a good
sort of front three quarters yeah it's
uh you're on track for a PB yeah
yeah yeah it would have been that I was
quite happy with my time yeah until the
last sort of yeah 20 minutes or whatever
I just sort of ruined it but how much of
a mental battle was it must have been
well next level yeah prepared for the
mental stuff because David Gilligan's
yeah yeah
that guy he annoys me
before
yeah two minutes after his run but um
yeah I mean the body shuts down that
shuts down yeah
um and the mine was willing because I
just wanted to get to the end of it but
yeah just you know I felt like a baby
giraffe taking it four steps you know
trying to take a drink or link for
yeah anymore and now done
on a flat track yeah so the Christchurch
Lancers in April so yeah is it around
Hagley Park yeah
I got the local local Legend on Strava
for the most amount of runs around
Higley Park oh wow all right we've got
to defend my territory right yeah oh
good stuff so mate obviously what a
career but like how do you look back on
your career as a when you reflect on it
yeah I think it is interesting coming
back to New Zealand now and it's it's
amazing how much it moves on and you
certainly don't get the recognition and
stuff that you did had when you were
here but I mean I've kind of been away
for seven years so it kind of felt like
I've retired from New Zealand Rugby for
seven years your old news and rugby like
you feel like obviously you like a
Crusaders Legend all black and mate
people people don't even know you yep
that's exactly right but I mean it's
quite refreshing I got used to it
overseas you can travel around Europe
and you go sit in a cafe by yourself and
not feel like a complete loser like yeah
it's just life and yeah I've become
accustomed to that and realize you know
well suddenly about it before I left it
you wouldn't do that but you know I'm
back to doing that again now got my
laptop and doing stuff so it's uh it was
quite nice to sort of come back but
yeah
um Yeah you sort of crack on with life
yeah it does feel like a long time ago
though that I was playing so like it
sort of feels like whether that's a head
knocks or not but uh it feels like a
lifetime ago you know you're real unsure
on your head knocks out I'm pretty
confident mate you're the one
oh I'm unsure hey but anyway we've gone
to the Instagram for some questions and
we've
can we ignore everything from Mike okay
moves one's uh deleted but we will ask
this one I'm not sure who this one came
from asking what happened when he threw
his strapping tape at Frank's in it
landed in his protein shake
uh yeah I mean that's that's what
happened uh
and that's one of my flat mates but yeah
of course I mean Frankie had a better
buffo and he wasn't as big as he was you
know but not that I was he was still way
bigger than me so I don't know why I did
that but yeah we were sitting on the
couch and there was a bin in the corner
tried to throw a strapping cap in the
bent landing and it's like the most
bounce off three walls and landed in his
protein the worst his face
and it was just like
I know what we're meant for here
brings it over to me [ __ ] take it out
it was an accident I didn't even know it
was in there you know like ah yeah
anyway
okay next one how accurate did you think
the actor who played you in the kick was
I can't remember it like honestly I do
because it was yeah I don't remember it
specifically but I remember being very
scrawny and yeah so probably pretty
accurate I'd say he's a good looking
bloke there wasn't me surely was he
did he ever like touch base with base
with you around like characteristics or
anything I don't even think he spoke to
be fair he ended up being quite a like a
minor yeah that's pretty much what
happened wasn't that
yeah they down solved your like surgery
and you know having to get your
injections at half time and all that
that could have yeah that doesn't make a
good story though more of a sob story
okay next one any tips for coping
mentally with high profile injuries
yep yep um just get stuck in the process
yeah
[Music]
come and all the consequences yeah it
makes sense so it's not so much worry
about you know if I'm missing
opportunity all that sort of stuff it is
trying to create and structure a
positive mindset
um to the whole thing that oh well this
is a good opportunity to work on my left
foot or come back stronger or get faster
um and this isn't just my mentality I've
seen other players do it some of them
train really hard some of them getting a
bit beat up yeah but he's depressed
about it but um yeah I mean you've got
two options you can either come up or
you can get back on the horse and
um if you don't want to give up be more
it makes gives you the answer doesn't it
also why not do it properly right like
that good one okay next one who sent it
the longest post Rugby World Cups
probably yourself
oh no no don't be silly although we did
have a good nudge um
I yeah I wouldn't know mate leaving I've
sort of missed out I went back
um
so that wasn't you know went back to
Christchurch pretty much the next day
um
Dean we all kept a good match yeah don't
really have an answer well I mean you
can imagine yeah yeah everyone probably
Corey Jane
okay next one who's the best player you
ever played with
um
you would have played with a few
actually yeah I think they're great yeah
I mean you'll say Richie
um
and like wasn't an ability thing he had
the ability but it was Morris commitment
to it
um and the consistency and it's yeah
around everything
um didn't hit off days didn't have you
know he didn't really do that
um
yeah I mean it's a guy that stands out I
played with plenty of good players
um but yeah he probably definitely
stands out well next time you see him at
the trampoline park yeah let him know
that he voted him as the greatest ever
yeah
special
okay last question always ask this one
always finish with this one best piece
of advice you have for a woodland
listener you've given a fair bit already
with injuries and how to manage your
life and finances but yeah
it's a good advice are you taking on
clients uh not yet no so it's a
compliance process that I'm going
through now so I've got to do all that
but you let me know and I hope that
whatever listeners will be flying in to
get some Financial advice from you after
this but anyway let's get to your advice
um I suppose with rugby related I'm
assuming
um well I suppose to see any I mean two
things that I would sort of say you get
them what you put out yeah
um the minute you're doing stuff to
um just took boxes you won't get better
so yeah really yeah that one sort of
thinking I guess that you know you'll
you'll the harder you work
the more you get pretty simple and the
other one is uh you know click the one
percenters and make habits you know it
is very hard to create good habits you
need to commit to them very easy to
accumulate bad habits
um so yeah you've got to actually really
make a conscious effort to collect the
one percenters and to make good habits
and then remove the bad habits and I
mean they build up pretty quickly
um and all of a sudden you don't have to
consciously think about them they become
part of you you get better you run once
you love that I've just read Atomic
habits I'm not sure if that's where you
got your advice from but that is oh
world class yeah I don't think that's
something that uh you know I do to the
statement I'm not a footy player anymore
um
but uh you might be you might be Richie
goes down early who knows
you're ready I'm training for a marathon
yeah oh mate well anyway it's been a
pleasure having you on the podcast what
a career what a journey you're a legend
of the game and you're a legend of
Christchurch so it's been awesome having
you on the podcast and going through
your story
pleasure absolute pleasure thank you
you're late
[Music]
[Music]